we'll start the show in just a second
but first i want to tell you about
today's
sponsors magic spoon is the cereal that
tastes
exactly like the delicious cereals from
your childhood except it has no sugar
tons of protein and only three net carbs
so it's perfect for a keto
diet to get free shipping go to
magicspoon.com
pacman and use the code pacman blinkist
is the app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an entire nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman
it's another day in trump's america
and therefore another one of these just
horrifying
dystopian authoritarian incidents
to tell you about donald trump has fired
the head
of cyber security for the department of
homeland security
why because the head of former head of
cyber security
said there was no widespread voter fraud
directly implying joe biden really did
win
donald trump really did lose we call
this reality we call this the facts we
call this re
living in the real world but
unfortunately doesn't work
if you work for donald trump i'm talking
about christopher krebs the director of
the cyber security
and infrastructure security agency
this is part of the department of
homeland security he reportedly expected
to be fired consider that for a second
this
president's capricious nature and
complete intolerance to what are to him
inconvenient truths it's so widely known
that his head of cyber security expected
to be fired
for saying the results are real
joe biden really won there was no
widespread voter fraud he
anticipated that saying that
would get him fired and the sequence
here was that krebs
agency put out a statement saying
we've looked at all of the allegations
and we find no evidence of voter fraud
in the 2020 election and the statement
included a section that said quote
the november third election was the most
secure in american history
right now across the country election
officials are
reviewing and double checking the entire
election process prior to finalizing the
result
when states have close elections many
will recount ballots all of these states
with close results in the 2020
presidential race
have paper records of each vote allowing
the ability to go back and count each
ballot
if necessary this is an added benefit
for security and resilience
this process allows for the
identification
and correction of any mistakes or errors
there is no evidence that any voting
system
deleted or lost votes changed
votes or was in any way compromised
of course trump's entire case that he
won is based on all sorts of claims of
exactly what christopher krebs said
there is no evidence of fraud observers
being blocked
votes flipping votes being deleted via
voting machine manipulation
it's the full gamut that trump has
alleged and it's the full gamut that
christopher krebs said
uh it didn't happen christopher krebs
putting out a statement saying
none of those things happened and donald
trump fires him
donald trump then tweeted about this
firing saying quote the recent statement
by kris krebs on the security of the
2020 election
was highly inaccurate in that there were
massive improprieties and fraud
including dead people voting that's been
debunked poll watchers not allowed into
polling locations
there were republican and democratic
poll watchers everywhere
glitches in the voting machines which
changed votes from trump to biden no
evidence of that
late voting and many more no evidence of
late voting of course as long as you
vote by election day votes can be
counted
as they arrive after the fact and then
he goes on to say therefore effective
immediately kris krebs has been
terminated
as director of the cyber security and
infrastructure
security agency there is no evidence of
any of the things donald trump is
alleging these are the things that
donald trump and his cronies have been
claiming
but courts and election officers have so
far not found merit to these claims
and indeed these tweets were flagged by
twitter
as being disputed claims about election
fraud
it's starting to seem like disputed
might not be a strong enough flag
for twitter i mean the things that
donald trump is tweeting
there's no evidence for them it's it's
not merely disputed it's like if i said
humans actually breathe helium not
oxygen and it pops up this is a disputed
claim about science well it's more than
disputed it's completely vapid
there's no evidence for it whatsoever
but in any case twitter
flags aside after being fired kris krebs
tweeted simply honored to serve
we did it right defend today
secure tomorrow at this point
is being fired by trump simply for doing
your job
a sort of badge of honor because you
know we've been talking about
so many of these hangers on around
donald trump
who have done his lying and his bidding
and his disinformation
uh spreading they really deserve to
never work again
kaylee mcinanny is an example we'll talk
about her later people like corey
lewandowski
um you know steve bannon these are
people who
if we had a fair world where actions had
fair consequences they would never work
again now i'm not calling for anybody to
starve
they should all have enough to eat hell
they should even have health care
but what i'm saying is that their
malfeasance is so
severe that they should be unemployable
by any moral right-thinking employer
okay
on the up they probably will all get
great consulting gigs or media gigs or
who knows what
on the other hand you have people who
simply are doing their job like for
example
kris krebs is in charge of analyzing
whether the election
took place in a secure fashion or
whether there was the widespread fraud
that has been alleged
he did his job he looked at it there's
no it's not even being asserted that
kris krebs was politically influenced or
strong-armed by someone or part of some
conspiracy to falsely give the election
to
it's not even being alleged in any
serious way maybe some on the internet
are alleging that but it's it's not even
an allegation he simply did his job and
this is the conclusion he came to
and he was fired he was just you're
fired that's it you're just gone
um is that now i mean have we fallen so
far
that that that is now a badge of honor
or some kind
uh these are bizarre times that we are
living in and hopefully at a certain
point
we will get back to a status quo that
makes a little bit more sense
right now it really doesn't and it's
horrifying our uh
i don't want to say our current allies
because some of them are distanced at
this point because of the trump
presidency
but our historical allies are regularly
horrified by what is going on in this
country
we have to start writing the ship and
hopefully i mean listen i i'm not going
to tell you it will happen but
hopefully the replacement of donald
trump with joe biden will be a start to
that
an inflection point of sorts donald
trump's
completely incompetent coronavirus
advisor dr scott atlas
has now suggested that you know what
maybe people should should
just go ahead and have the big indoor
thanksgivings this year
because it might be the last
thanksgiving for lots of people
anyway now i read the headline and i
thought this can't be true
it can't actually be that bad let me
look at the video
i then watch the video and it's even
worse than the headline when you
actually see
the complete disregard for human life
the complete lack of empathy the
complete lack of understanding
the video is worse than the headline
let's take a look and just as a reminder
who the hell is scott atlas scott atlas
is the doctor
that when trump pushed fauci out from
being sort of publicly part of his inner
coronavirus circle appearing with him
at press briefings and the like when
fauci was pushed out scott atlas was
brought in
now scott atlas is not an epidemiologist
he's not an infectious disease doctor
he's not a
pulmonologist an immunologist he's he's
a radiologist and he has become donald
trump's top guy on coronavirus why
because he'll simply go along with
anything donald trump says take a look
at this
they're suffering from with isolation
and this kind of isolation is one of the
unspoken tragedies of the elderly
who are now being told don't see your
family at thanksgiving
for many people this is their final
thanksgiving believe it or not
what are we doing here i think we have
to have a policy which i have been
advocating
which is a whole person whole health
policy
it's not about just stopping cases of
covid
we have to talk about the damage of the
policy itself
so what does the federal government do
it's what i've advised
so that is a neuroradiologist
advocating for things what
this guy is just disgusting and
you know when i want to talk about
infectious disease i don't
typically think to call a radiologist
this is no offense to radiologists
we have a handful of radiologists in our
audience that i know about
we probably have more radiologists in
our audience that i don't know about
two of them actually emailed me and they
said david you know
i don't find it offensive when people
say why the hell is a radiologist
up there on trump's coronavirus task
force so prominently
they wrote to me and said i'm a
radiologist i have no business dictating
public health policy during a global
pandemic period
why is scott atlas doing anything here
is question number one
stanford university which is where scott
atlas was a senior fellow at the hoover
institution
before joining trump's coronavirus team
has already distanced itself from scott
atlas's comments political
observers who have some connection to
reality have been criticizing scott
atlas's presence in this group
and what scott atlas doesn't seem to be
saying
is that we might make this thanksgiving
the last one for lots of people
if we hold these huge indoor gatherings
which will spread the virus
and will kill people who could have
otherwise had many more thanksgivings
now it's also sort of strange scott
atlas talks about the elderly
some of these elderly folks might be on
their last thanksgiving
regardless of whether uh there was a
pandemic or not
remember that the death rate for
coronavirus
triples for those in their 60s relative
to those in their 50s
and then the death rate almost triples
again
for those in their 70s relative to those
in their 60s
people in their 50s 60s and 70s often
live a long time like
if you're 59 and you have a
significantly higher death rate
than those under 50. when he says the
elderly might be dying in the next year
anyway
is he talking about 59 year olds is he
talking about 65 year olds is he talking
about 75
like what is he even talking about here
when he says this may be the last
thanksgiving anyway for lots of these
folks
who are at higher risk if they contract
coronavirus
delusional completely delusional
and this is the doctor who has trump's
ear
if you say well there's all these
different people who are doing good work
uh um uh peter hotez and you know
dr anthony fauci and our friend isaac
bogash
who's in canada i mean the point is
there's so many doctors doing good work
and talking sense here and it's scott
atlas who has donald trump's ear
once again it's the worst people i
previously said
almost any random american would have
better handled coronavirus than trump
and you might be wondering well like how
would a construction worker
or an accountant or a preschool teacher
or a dental hygienist like how
do you what do you mean how would they
have handled it better than trump
most people would not be so delusional
delusionally narcissistic
that they would think they know more
than doctors most people
would just say wow i'm in charge of the
pandemic great
what kind of doctors and public health
officials and scientists know about
pandemics
let's turn it over to them and you would
end up with a better situation than what
we ended up with
trump did worse than random people
by imposing his ignorance and his
delusions and his narcissism on the
situation
you were seeing the same thing now with
dr scott atlas almost
any doctor would better handle this my
dentist
who has been my dentist since i was five
years old
if you put my dentist in charge my
dentist would immediately say
great let's bring in an epidemiologist
let's bring in a public health expert
let's bring in an infectious disease
expert a pulmonologist a medical ethic
you know whatever
you guys tell me what to do what to say
and we'll get it done any one of the
doctors
on joe biden's coronavirus task force
even oncologist and medical ethicist
zeke emanuel
would better handle this than the
combination of scott atlas and donald
trump
they regularly find the worst people
to do the absolute worst things all the
time like clockwork and remember
one of the selling points about donald
trump
was this is a businessman sort of like a
project manager he'll hire the best
people
he'll put the best people in charge and
it's all going to be fantastic
there were very few even ostensible
selling points about donald trump the
ones that there were were bogus
he's failed on every single one of them
including famously i will hire the best
people and put the best people in in
positions of power
we will be lucky to now get out of this
with under i mean you know we're looking
at 400
000 americans dead by february
maybe even more we will be lucky to keep
the numbers that low and at one point
remember donald trump said
forget about 15 cases will soon be zero
at one point when this was a thing
donald trump was saying we we might lose
50 or 60 000 people but it's not going
to be more than that we're looking at
400
000 maybe even half a million let me
know where you are
on the next three months of the virus
via twitter
where you can find me at d pacman the
david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
one of our sponsors today is magic spoon
the reason i'm such a fan of magic spoon
is they allow me to enjoy the delicious
breakfast cereals i loved as a kid
without all the sugar and without the
unhealthy ingredients because magic
spoon makes breakfast cereal
that you really can't tell apart from
those tasty sugary cereals that we all
know
but each serving of magic spoon has no
sugar
three net carbs and 11 grams of protein
so it's perfect for someone on a low
carb
keto diet just anybody trying to eat
healthier and cut back on the sugar
you can choose from cocoa frosted fruity
cinnamon blueberry or peanut butter they
all taste amazing
and magic spoon now lets you create your
own customized variety pack
with the flavors you choose they really
do stand by their product and will
refund 100 percent of your money if you
don't love it
no questions asked go to magicspoon.com
to build your own custom variety box
today
make sure to use promo code pacman to
get free shipping
the link is right underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
our little program here is mostly funded
by
viewers and listeners through the
membership program you can sign up at
joinpackman.com
quick easy you get a daily extra show
produced just for our members and you
can take advantage of the coupon code
fresh start all one word all lowercase
fresh start
saves you hugely off of the cost of a
new
membership apply the code fresh start to
the membership of your choice
or don't it's up to you at
joinpackman.com
yesterday we briefly discussed this
story on the bonus show and in the hours
following the recording of yesterday's
bonus show the story has exploded now
with corroboration so let me kind of uh
tell tell you what's going on here and
it is
it's it's wild a staffer for georgia
secretary of state
brad raffensberger said yesterday
that on a phone call with republican
senator lindsey graham
lindsay asked could state officials
throw out some ballots to help donald
trump win the state of georgia
this is not an anonymous source this is
election implementation manager gabriel
sterling who has come forward and said
yeah i heard the same thing
that brad raffensberger heard so this is
now corroboration
the story as we knew it yesterday
morning was that georgia secretary of
state brad raffensberger
said you know i had a phone call with
lindsey graham and lindsey graham
seemed to be implying um
let's see if you can throw out some
ballots and
he was referring of course to absentee
ballots which skew heavily
in favor of president joe biden in the
state of georgia
as is the case in many states so that
was the initial claim from brad
raffensberger
lindsay denied the claim saying it's
ridiculous
i didn't do it i wasn't trying to get
ballots thrown out or anything like it
even though raffensberger seemed
very very clear about what he heard from
lindsey graham lindsey graham saying hey
you know
if there was political bias maybe poll
workers accepted ballots that they
shouldn't have
what if we find some ballots and we
identify some counties and we toss them
out if we find that there's a high
rate of non-matching signatures and
raffensberger reported being stunned
that
lindsey graham was suggesting this and
uh
said it sure seemed as though lindsey
graham was trying to go down that road
so that was the the initial claim and
lindsey graham denied it and then now
again uh gabriel sterling has said i was
on that phone call i heard the exact
same thing from lindsey graham so
we found the attempted voter fraud guys
the calls are coming from inside the
house
it's lindsey graham saying how about we
toss some ballots in the trash
graham has said all along oh i was
trying to find
out how does georgia election law work
does anybody believe that and graham
also when asked about this said
the president didn't urge me to do this
now that's one of those meaningless
political statements that
it it could the letter of that could be
true but in spirit it might be a
complete and total lie
when lindsey graham i mean listen maybe
lindsey graham came up with this idea on
his own maybe donald trump came up with
the idea
but lindsey graham might well be right
by the letter that
trump never er trump never called
lindsay and said listen
call georgia ask them to throw ballots
in the trash
the way these things would work is that
a trump staffer
suggests to lindsey graham what would
happen if you were to get on the phone
with brad raffensberger
and see what they might be able to do
this is like um
you know in argentina and other
countries my experience is with
argentina
sometimes there are corrupt police in
argentina
and you know you might get pulled over
and a police officer starts with oh you
know i
not only were you speeding but i think
that uh
your your brake light is messed up and i
think that there's too much pollution
coming from your tailpipe
i don't know i might have to get uh
backup down here and
you know and then you say the code you
don't say
can i bribe you right you say wow
that's really inconvenient is there some
other way i might be able to resolve
this today
could we figure out a way to resolve
this right now
and then this game is played of well
what did you have in mind
right that's the way politics is done
it's not
lindsay it's donald tell them to throw
ballots out
so lindsey saying he wasn't urged by
trump is completely meaningless
now is this illegal i i actually don't
know i mean
is is the suggestion from lindsey graham
if it were proven
is it against the law it sounds like it
should be but i really don't know
and you just had to know that once
republicans started screeching about
voter fraud
it was them who they were the ones who
were going to try to commit it
it's projection and many people have
written to me saying david
brad raffensberger is a republican why
is he why is he going public
and throwing lindsey graham under the
bus yeah raffensberger is a republican
but he probably realizes there's really
no way to just throw
out large batches of legal ballots even
if he had an idea of how he might be
able to throw out some batches of
ballots
braffen's burger probably realizes that
the risks
dramatically outweigh the rewards
especially since flipping georgia if he
was able to do it
wouldn't actually give donald trump a
presidential
win in the electoral college and in
order for raffensberger to get himself
out of possible trouble
maybe he's decided to just go public and
throw lindsey graham under the bus now
there's one other possibility
maybe raffensberger is just acting with
integrity instead of hyper partisanship
i'm so conditioned not to assume that
that i'm mentioning that second but
it's conceivable that raffensberger is
just acting with integrity here now one
other thing
we and others are calling this the real
voter fraud
this really isn't voter fraud this is
election fraud
which is the real fraud we have to worry
about voter fraud is this retail
strategy
that republicans and trump have been
crying about someone trying to vote
twice
someone showing up and saying i'm giving
the name of a dead person and casting a
ballot or
submitting a bunch of fake absentee
ballots that's really inefficient those
are stupid ways to try to steal an
election
what we're talking about here is
election fraud which is abusing the law
trying to do mass disenfranchisement of
voters
this includes stuff like using weak
signature laws to throw out votes
from people with maybe black sounding
names or hispanic sounding names or
whatever maybe people from poor areas
intimidating people at the polls doing
voter purges
that's election fraud and that's really
the concern
and if this is true about lindsey graham
what is being alleged
it should be career ending it look it
should be indictment garden
garnering to be perfectly frank but
nothing matters anymore to this party
and more than likely
lindsey graham is going to get away with
this i hope i'm wrong but i think he
will get away with it
you might imagine that faced with a
large defeat in the 2020 election
donald trump's press secretary and
senior campaign advisor kaylee mckennany
would be quietly preparing to ride off
into the sunset to some media gig to
some consulting gig
somewhere joe biden is likely going to
end up with 306 electoral votes just
like donald trump had in 2016 but unlike
donald trump who lost the popular vote
by 3 million
joe biden is on track to win the popular
vote by 5
5.5 maybe even 6 million votes
when all of the counting is done but
it's not stopping kaylee mckennany
she will not stop humiliating herself
and we're going to look at some clips
today
i'm wondering maybe whether there's a
long game that she's playing here like
maybe kaylee
has the sense or she's been told if you
can keep this up
uh at some point in his next endeavor
donald trump is going to give you a
really cushy gig
because quite frankly i don't know how
else we can understand
why she's behaving in this way maybe i'm
trying to apply logic where there is no
logic let's see what you think after you
see these clips
so to start with last night donald trump
and many republicans
were hopeful that wayne county in
michigan was not going to certify
their election results just that one
county
and because the trump campaign has had
no victories so far
speaking you know legal victories they
were starting to say
wow wayne county won't certify we won
here is kaylee mckennany cheering it
with sean hannity last night
wayne county canvassers say we cannot
certify this election because
of these witnesses they're real people
and one reporter tweeted out this is the
first time
in my 20-year history i've ever seen
something like this a county commission
refused to certify
it's because for the first time you have
a president for fighting for the
forgotten men and women in detroit
and philadelphia and democrat cities
across the nation now
unfortunately for her these claims about
wayne county
were bogus and within minutes of kaylee
saying this to sean hannity
wayne county did certify the election
as they should have and michigan is now
a closed book essentially then we go
from talking about michigan to talking
about pennsylvania
as you may have heard rudy giuliani
yesterday
went over the line from just being
donald trump's tv lawyer to actually
arguing before a court it reportedly was
a huge embarrassment but here is sean
hannity saying i heard rudy was
brilliant in court yesterday
all right in pennsylvania rudy giuliani
argued the case today
i've heard from more than a few people
that he was absolutely brilliant
in his arguments today what's the status
of that so the idea of rudy being
brilliant in court at this point is
hilarious and we later heard that rudy
made no sense at all in court yesterday
at one point rudy giuliani apparently
raised the idea that some kind of
mafia-like organization
stole the election for joe biden in
court rudy giuliani brought this up
and it was reportedly a legal
embarrassment for giuliani
let's continue here is kaylee mckennany
holding up papers again it's almost a
requirement now if you go on tv to argue
that joe biden stole the election
you have to hold up affidavits and sean
hannity mentions this
and says kaylee show them how the pages
aren't really blank like some people
said these papers these affidavits
234 pages of sworn affidavits under
penalty
of perjury by the way county
what did cnn say about when you held
them up on this program didn't they
accuse you of holding up blank sheets
that's right they did about a 10 minute
monologue saying these were blank
they're not blank in fact these pages of
paper
from one county were the reason that you
had a county
level wayne county canvasser say we
cannot certify this election because
of these witnesses they're real people
now of course
they did certify and the issue isn't
whether the pages are blank
it's that the stuff on the pages is
absolute and complete nonsense so that
was last night
i think um that last night she was
senior campaign advisor on the sean
hannity program
now this morning kaylee went back on fox
news this time on fox and friends
and today she was no longer trump
campaign senior advisor today
she was white house press secretary and
host brian kilmeade
clarifies that this is a game they play
thanks so much griff meanwhile let's
bring in kaylee mcandy she's functioning
with us today as the white house press
secretary
so today she's white house press
secretary on fox news remember last week
on fox and friends she was not white
house press secretary last week on fox
and friends
she was trump campaign senior advisor so
when they asked her questions about what
does trump believe about this or that
last week
she said oh that really would be a
question for the white house
which of course she is the spokesperson
for the white house but last week she
was not appearing in that capacity
um the question here it's completely
kafkaesque is the way i would describe
it
here uh kaylee was asked about donald
trump cancelling his thanksgiving trip
to his resort in florida and kaylee
frames it as
he's hard at work now the truth is trump
is in a bunker mentality
he's not being seen in public maybe
he'll take questions today
we've not seen him uh take questions for
weeks at this point in time
but kaylee says he's just so hard at
work he's going to stay at the white
house
so kaley we know the president and
melania the first lady are going to
celebrate thanksgiving there at the
white house and
normally they go down to mar-a-lago i
know they're going to pardon the turkeys
why they decide to stay in d.c
this year well the president's hard at
work he's hard at work on covet among
other issues
uh drawing down our number of troops in
afghanistan and iraq bringing our men
and women home
um he's hard at work um and so he's
staying here at the white house and it
will be a lovely thanksgiving for him
and the first lady
i'm here in the white house all right do
you think we'll hear from the president
soon
uh perhaps that's up to president trump
um you know sometimes he'll make the
decision to come out on any given moment
but i'm sure you'll hear from him at the
right moment
now donald trump has not been hard at
work when you look at donald trump's
schedule this week
you see that he has had nothing on his
schedule
other than golf and lunch with mike
pence and it's been
weeks since he's taken any questions
from the media
just a couple more clips here kaylee
dismisses the public health guidelines
uh about slowing the spread of
coronavirus as
orwellian when they bring up uh at fox
and friends
the fact that we have cartoonishly high
numbers of coronavirus cases
but we know all across the country
kaylee cases
are spiking unfortunately and this is
the week
before thanksgiving when families are
going to be together
and there are a number of governors who
are suggesting look
you don't need to be in a in a big group
particularly if people are outside your
bubble
what do you think of these suggestions
and guidelines some of the governors
have given
in advance of this because it is a super
contagious disease
yeah i think a lot of the guidelines
you're seeing are orwellian
let me start by saying the cdc has put
out considerations
as we prepare to go about thanksgiving
about socially distancing wearing masks
doing what you can
there's a whole list a page of very good
considerations and in that they say
we're not recommending a certain number
of people but we are giving
considerations that you should
put in place it's orwellian now to do
what every
sensible country is doing that's really
something and then here kaylee mckenna
he continues talking about a second
trump administration
as if we're just weeks from donald trump
being sworn into a second term
job uh a stockpile that was left empty
by obama biden that he's filled up since
then he's left an infrastructure in
place
uh where covid can be handled um and we
believe that
we will do so going forward in a second
trump administration all right
okay i mean yeah there's not much else
to say about that
and then lastly of course white house
press secretary
kaylee mckennany will not commit
to a peaceful transfer of power
if the president doesn't win and joe
biden is
it's proven that he is the elected
president what happens with the transfer
of power
will it be peaceful look this president
has always said um
he will engage in a peaceful transfer of
power if the facts bear out that way but
the president believes and
so too uh do many others that if every
legal vote is counted
uh he will remain president he's
pursuing litigation
but this president always wants what's
in the best interest of our country
so day after day another embarrassment
another humiliation and i do hope that
once
joe biden selects a press secretary for
his administration
the relationship between press secretary
and and the country will normalize
it's been hysterical and histrionic
during the trump administration it was
that way with sean spicer
was there somebody there was somebody in
between oh sarah huckabee sanders
how could i forget um and now with
kaylee mckennay
it's been absolutely ridiculous and
hopefully we'll see something a little
bit more normal
during the joe biden administration
follow us
on instagram for more on this and
other stories i'm on instagram at
david.pacman
and you can also follow the show at
david pakman show
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
welcome back to the david pakman show
all right today we are going to be
speaking with senior advisor
for the joe biden for president campaign
christophel alex
who uh has worked on uh you've been
working on campaigns for a long time i
mean you're not you're not
new to this that's right i'm a bit of an
old timer you can tell from my grades
i've had a
a couple of these campaigns behind me
i'm a viejito they call me
in the campaign so let's i want to talk
let's start maybe by talking about the
latino vote i've been speaking
on my show but also with my audience
over on my spanish language show
on the estrella network about the latino
vote and the growing
importance demographically of the latino
vote in the united states
i was slightly disappointed but not
altogether surprised
that a higher share of the latino vote
did not go to joe biden now i know that
there's a number of ways that we could
spin this we could look at specific
states we could look at
sort of the range of of the vote
of the latino vote that typically goes
to the republican candidate and
certainly what donald trump got is
within that range but
is there any disappointment on your side
that it was not um
an even more overwhelming victory for
joe biden among that group
you know i'll say that we're very proud
of the work of the campaign
and all of the work that preceded the
campaign
in critical battleground states around
the country decades of organizing work
uh from young people from immigration
rights organizations to
puerto rican organizations to others
that have led to this
election which i think is a uh an
important moment if you look at
the trajectory of building latino
political power i think
we're approaching a high water mark and
uh yes uh the latino community as
as you know better than anybody is is
not a monolith and so
we do want to look more specifically at
data from
states or even within states and you
know when we set out
in the general election with our latino
program
we set a goal to match the high water
mark of the 2012
obama biden re-election campaign that
hit 71 percent
of the latino vote we are just about
there as
as the numbers are calculated and
tabulated we're at about
70 71 percent range right now in some of
the more crucial
uh uh uh battleground states that's
nationally if you look at some of the
if you drill down a little bit you look
at a place like wisconsin for example
where we had a hundred thousand plus
latino vote turnout
in those places latinos uh really
exceeded that
hitting almost 80 percent if you look at
maricopa county when we
flipped arizona or in pima county you're
looking at over 80 percent some places
85
of the of the vote um it's also the
reason why
um you know we kept uh we flipped
arizona that's why we kept
nevada that's why we elected a united
states senator latino united states
senator
uh in new mexico uh and and if you look
at pennsylvania
a huge surge of latino voters a lot of
puerto a a lot of puerto ricans there
and again
because of the hard work that preceded
the campaign and and proudly i will say
because of the campaign significant
investments over 100 million dollars
uh to reach latino voters you know we
exceeded uh
almost that 80 mark in pennsylvania
again proving to be the margin of
difference we're very excited about that
yeah okay good so those are some good
examples i mean let's let's now talk
about one
that that's an area of concern to me
we've known for a long time that
uh while the the american latino voter
community is not a monolith one of the
it is a very
left uh community in total with the
notable exception of cuban americans and
we know about this sort of anti-castro
reflexive thing
and fears of so-called socialism which
will often influence particularly
florida cuban americans to vote
at higher levels for republicans than
than we see
in other states it would be huge would
it not
to be able to bring over more of that
cuban american community
in florida because with without florida
the map for republic
republicans nationally gets systemically
very very difficult and i'm wondering
what you think it will take
to bring over more cuban-american voters
that's a great question um you know i'll
start by saying
uh you know miami-dade um and
and south florida um a true battleground
and we
uh we fought very hard and competed for
every single voter
uh there and and uh you know we we did
win
uh by a good margin the latino vote in
florida we've got some work to do
uh with with cubans um and also uh
venezuelans and others
and if you look a little deeper i think
um you know
uh president-elect did very well with
younger voters uh
young latino voters especially those
were very high uh
boat share for us um but we've got some
work to do with some of the older voters
especially the cuban voters and
you know i'll say it's hard to compare
this election to 2016 when
secretary clinton got a lot of um
support from the cuban community part of
the reason for that was
if you remember the the the presidential
primary in 2016 on the republican side
donald trump spent a lot of time uh
attacking marco rubio for example
among other things that that brought
down his percentage
among cuban voters but as you pointed
out that um usually a higher percent
goes republican there so
we are going to do some work there and i
think part of it we'll see um
uh trending uh in our direction very
soon is um
you know once a president-elect joe
biden and and
takes office along with his vice
president kamala harris
we're going to do a lot of work uh um to
make sure that we can expand democracy
uh in cuba uh that we strengthen
relationships
uh throughout latin and central america
and make sure that we're doing the
things that we need to do
uh that will eventually uh again this is
going to be good policy but eventually
will yield uh better percentages in some
of these communities
when we look at the politics of it yeah
you mentioned that
this year donald trump was not attacking
marco rubio in the way that he was
in 2016. one of the other differences i
noticed and i wonder if you if you think
this is relevant electorally
is that merely by chance not because
donald trump's views have become more
enlightened but merely by chance
there was much less discussion about
mexican rapists and criminals in the
last six months there was much less
discussion about the wall
although at rallies trump would say the
wall is being built and mexico's paying
for it obviously both lies
by by sheer distraction it seems from
what's been going on
trump did less of that and i'm wondering
if that
also ended up helping him a little bit
in the end
yeah that's a great question i've
wondered that myself and you know
i i did expect a lot more of the typical
uh vitriol demagoguing latino
communities especially immigrants
and it was there no doubt uh just not um
on the front page or the first thing out
of his mouth uh that we would see in
2018 or in 2016.
right you know part of the reason for
that uh is is
undoubtedly the fact that uh our country
is facing
uh a pandemic uh and the economy is
is is in bad shape again because of
donald trump's failed leadership
and that was top of mind for voters and
he tried very hard no doubt
to to try and make the election anything
about himself or his failed leadership
um but at the end it becomes a
referendum um
on his handling of kovid his complete
and utter
uh failure there and so it was hard for
him to uh to turn that script now
um i will say uh even though he spoke
uh perhaps less about immigrants uh
and and didn't attack latinos and
immigrants as much
as he did previously his administration
wasted no time
trying to to do harm uh to the
communities and
uh one of the first things that you will
see uh president-elect when he becomes
president
uh joe biden do is undo much of the harm
that donald trump and his administration
has done yeah so
i want to talk about that next so let's
get into that we we've started to see
this list of
possible day one executive orders we've
heard about getting back in the who
paris climate trans military ban maybe
something can be done in terms of the
trade relationship with
china via executive order and there's
this question mark around daca
and and dreamers what is the day one
plan what can be done via executive
order with that program
quite a bit uh actually and um our new
uh
chief of staff white house chief of
staff ron plain uh
last week talked about some of those day
one priorities and
uh one of those uh is very important to
joe biden
uh and kamala harris uh is
protecting dreamers so there will be
executive action
on day one um and there will also be um
an immigration bill uh that includes uh
obviously dreamers and
and and their families and and a pathway
to citizenship a roadmap to citizenship
for the 11 million undocumented in this
country that's
that's going to happen uh right away uh
now of course we're going to have to do
a lot of work to get the immigration
bill passed but through executive action
there's going to be a very swift
undertaking to protect to protect
dreamers
yeah i i think that if democrats don't
take the senate
tax reform and the health care expansion
that joe biden wants to
do i think they don't happen i do think
that because
some of these immigration issues are
actually relevant to some republican
senators
i i think that the chance of doing
something on immigration is
slightly higher if them even without
having the senate but a lot is riding on
those races in georgia isn't it
a lot's riding on those races and what i
will say
is um we're hopeful uh and again you saw
georgia uh turning blue you're seeing a
record enthusiasm a record vote there
very diverse
electorate all of those things uh bode
well
um but i i think it's important to
remember
joe biden uh has a very distinguished
public service career
in the senate uh he knows how to work
across the aisle
to get big things done for america
whether that was
um beating the nra not once but twice
pushing for the very first climate
change legislation when he was in the
senate
whether that was advocating and and
getting past
the violence against women's act i mean
the list goes on and on he does very
well
in these situations i mean healthcare
again uh the aca another prime example
of him
uh working hard uh uh and and being able
to
to get things done with democrats and
with republicans and so
you can expect from major pieces of
legislation like that
for joe biden to do what he does best
which is to to work with others to unify
not just our country but to but to unify
our government to tackle these major
challenges
yeah i don't doubt for a second joe
biden's ability
willingness and interest to do that uh i
just think it's naive to think these
republicans are going to participate in
anything that doesn't
obviously and completely benefit uh what
what they've
laid out as their priorities i think the
republican party has changed
dramatically but
i remain cautiously optimistic my i
think the concern among some in the
progressive left is
what would joe biden have to compromise
in order to get some of these
republicans on board
you know i here's the thing i
as a progressive myself um you know i
think what
what we need to remember here is
the country is on this precipice right
now
uh as joe biden talked about this during
the campaign
in our darkest times uh our nation has
been able to come together
and and achieve the greatest good uh
if you look at some of the moments in
history whether it's coming out of the
great depression whether it's coming out
of world war
ii uh um we're able to
to to come together and and do amazing
things
um and i know it sounds naive
but i am uh optimistic that we are at
one of these moments now where we're
gonna have to do
we're going to have to number one get
this pandemic the virus under control
but then
there's an opportunity and partly
because we have to
to rebuild this economy and there are a
lot of major components that will go
into that
including uh major investments uh again
we'll we're going to work
uh with republicans and and
conservatives and
progressives and independents and and
all americans to get this
done but we need to be able to rebuild
the economy we need to make sure that we
get climate change
under control uh and there's ways where
we can
uh build millions of jobs in this
country that are that are green jobs and
so that's part of it that's one of the
things we need to do and the other is
you know with all of the uh the the the
racial justice issues that are now
getting
uh a lot of the attention that they that
they deserve uh there's gonna be a way
to address some of these systemic
uh racial issues in our country again uh
even though we're dealing with this
pandemic and having to rebuild this
economy there are opportunities within
that to address some of these things and
yeah i mean no no disagreement for me
in terms of the stakes or the priorities
um skepticism significant skepticism
about
the current republican party as uh as a
participant in that
uh but but we we will we will very soon
start to see how it plays out
we've been speaking with christo alex
who is a senior advisor
for the joe biden for president campaign
i really appreciate your time today
oh it was an honor thanks for having me
the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way is through
membership which includes the world
famous
bonus show as well as commercial free
audio and video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpackman.com
coupon code saves you 40 vote soon 18.
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
this is super interesting in the last
few days there have been some tweets
floating around
an article saying that the american
right has now gone from the war on
christmas to the war on thanksgiving as
a sort of replacement to the
non-existent war on christmas that
they've been touting for like a decade
at this point
so as a reminder the war on christmas is
supposed hostility to christmas
and two christians that the right says
exists
in the united states by the left and it
mostly this stems from the idea that a
few years ago
um there there have been since a few
years ago there have been many people
saying you know
saying happy holidays is more inclusive
than saying merry christmas when you
don't know somebody's religion
listen if you're a christian and you
know you're talking to a christian say
say merry christmas
it might be more inclusive like at
starbucks for example or maybe at a
place of work or whatever
to say happy holidays that's it that's
the genesis
and the catalyst for the so-called war
and war on christmas
that the right has been talking about
now for a decade
we have uh thanksgiving coming up here
in the united states
during a global pandemic and so there
are more and more governors and state
public health officials saying you
really shouldn't have
large indoor gatherings at thanksgiving
that's how the virus spreads and in fact
even at this point in time
most contagion is happening inside
people's homes
either between family members or friends
who are spending time
uh in close proximity to each other in
indoor spaces we know the virus spreads
more indoors than outdoors
we know that being around someone for
hours rather than minutes is more likely
to spread it
we're closing in potentially on 200 000
cases per day in a few weeks
yesterday we had 1600 deaths so
especially
with vaccines hopefully coming soon it
seems
this is a time to be careful rather than
reckless
so the war on christmas right wingers
have now taken the opportunity to claim
that the left is waging a war on
thanksgiving here's one short clip
this is a guy named charlie kirk who
shockingly
is sometimes promoted by donald trump
and others take a look at this
the left has always hated thanksgiving
thanksgiving can be interpreted as a
religious holiday if you believe in
giving thanks to a creator
but they hate thanksgiving because they
believe there is nothing you should be
thankful for in america this is an awful
place
it is cancerous rotten to the core tear
it all down
burn it from within why would you be
thankful instead we need
a revolution
remember as the students for a
democratic society radicals once wrote
in the
sixties they said conflict is the origin
of everything what happens when you're
thankful
by definition you're less likely to be
involved and engaged
in conflict
thanksgiving is supposed to de-escalate
any sort of pre-existing
issues in our country
and now they're using the virus as an
excuse for you not to be thankful
we'll be right back now charlie clearly
is just upset that he's still not
allowed to sit at the adult table at
thanksgiving they're keeping him at the
kids table and he's just absolutely
furious
but everything he's saying is completely
untrue the left has never been opposed
to being thankful
the questions about thanksgiving were
never religious they were more about
acknowledging that thanksgiving has
another side to it
just like columbus day which is the
genocide of native americans by early
american settlers
but that's not even the issue here what
i want to remind you
is that the entire war on thanksgiving
thing is not new they're now
so the point here is they now are acting
as though this is a fact-based reaction
to guidelines around the pandemic
a year ago there was no pandemic and
they were still talking about a war on
thanksgiving check this clip out from
fox news
last thanksgiving more than a year ago
prepare their travel plans and dinner
menus for
turkey day otherwise known as
thanksgiving canceled culture
has turned on the holiday the huffington
post seriously suggesting americans skip
spending time with family instead for
going travel to save our planet
here to react comedian michael loftus
michael great to see as always let's put
on a screen the title of this article it
is called the environmental
impact of your thanksgiving dinner and
here's what they want to get rid of
cue full screen they want to take turkey
out of the turkey dinner because of your
carbon footprint
cut down on travel for both yourself and
your food i'm often interested in my
foods travel
and pare down the endless sides
and apps now when i heard this all
joking aside i got viscerally angry
because to me
this is the latest attempt to tear down
an american tradition
that was fine and didn't need any help
what say you
amen brother cut it out that is not a
skit
that is a real segment from fox news uh
from last year
here is another fox news segment from
last year
we've heard about the war on christmas
but now college students are declaring a
war on thanksgiving forget the war on
christmas the left is now going after
thanksgiving
this was pizzas the war on thanksgiving
they want to fight a war on thanksgiving
they lost the war on christmas
they want to fight again pc police well
they have a new target
thanksgiving canceled culture has turned
on the holiday
cancel thanksgiving dinner very sad to
announce
we have to cancel thanksgiving all
across america a growing number of
students
and professors claim we need to throw
away our turkeys
no turkey no traveling cranberry sauce
and mashed potatoes are bad for the
planet
we need to cancel thanksgiving cancel
thanksgiving telling america
america to cancel cancel
thanksgiving cancel thanksgiving and
control
how many kids you have i'm not
making this up so there's a few things
going on here first of all
money is being made by these people just
creating
anger among their followers for anything
there's actually
lots to be angry about we have food
lines in texas this week in one of the
richest countries in the world
we have a president who has stopped
doing anything as a global 100-year
pandemic is raging he's had nothing on
his schedule for a week
we could have health care for everybody
but we don't like there's no shortage of
things to be mad about
but none of that anger would be useful
to the american right
so instead they get people fired up
about these inane
non-issues and conspiracy theories joe
biden stole the election
there's a war on thanksgiving and that
is horrifying but it is a very lucrative
grift for them and then the irony of it
if you can call it that
is that they are actually doing what
they claim the left is doing in other
words
they say the left wants people mad about
either christmas or thanksgiving or
whatever
that's not true they want people mad
at the left though about the
non-existent attacks on christmas and
thanksgiving
that they claim exist exist they are
doing
what they falsely claim the left is
actually doing
it's just more projection and it's not
going to stop anytime soon
hey this is kind of funny i was on the
dr phil show
like i didn't go anywhere but a clip of
the show was
on the dr phil show and this is really
funny it ended up
being very underwhelming i'm going to
play the clip for you um
dr phil's show producers contacted me
months ago saying david
we loved your interview about the
addictiveness of casinos
with an author who wrote about this
named natasha dao shull
and we want to use a clip for the show
we're going to feature you and natasha
can we do it
sure yeah my only requirement is let me
air the clip on my show without
filing a copyright claim i think my
audience would get a kick out of it
months of legal work and negotiations
and paperwork
i was imagining wow i mean this there's
so much
lawyer time going into this i'm sure
this is gonna be like a big feature
i think i'm on screen about four seconds
okay don't look away
because you might miss me this is an
episode i guess about
gambling problems take a look casinos
are deliberately designed like a maze
to trap and confuse you there's no
clocks on the wall
you cannot help but be overwhelmed by
the bombardment of sounds
and light you are getting a little dose
of gambling in your brain every three
seconds
it's a gambling iv so you try to crowd
objects bring the ceiling height down
and create a sense
of sort of clutter coziness confusion
you're going to hear ding ding ding ding
it's going to light up
flash what if those jingles and
bells and whistles are actually there to
encourage you to make risky decisions
you go into that trance that zone that
box nobody can touch you
you have escaped from reality no one can
ask you for anything
so that that's it those four seconds
pretty underwhelming so to me the shock
is the amount of
paperwork for a few seconds of me on dr
phil it must be a lawyer's dream to be
clearing rights for these shows if they
spent
two months three months of legal work to
get four seconds of me
i can't even imagine what's going on
with you know copyrighted music or
whatever else so
that was me on dr phil um
i i don't know what else to say maybe
maybe it's interesting in some way
but uh the back story is lots and lots
of legal negotiations to make it happen
we have a voicemail number on this show
here's an interesting voicemail
about something people have written to
me about before my disclaimers uh let's
take a listen to what the caller has to
say
hey david i've got a new year's
resolution for you
yes how about no more
of the disclaimers for idiots all right
you don't have to explain every time
that chris wallace is not our friend the
lincoln project is not our friend
fox news are not as blah blah blah blah
blah
if people on the left are too dumb
to ever accept that maybe
someone outside of their tribe has
something reasonable to say
from time to time do you really want
them to be a subscriber
so this is completely fair so they're
referring to yesterday i did a segment
where chris wallace said one thing that
made sense
and i kind of gave this disclaimer where
i said listen i'm not saying fox news is
trustworthy i'm not saying these are our
friends
all i'm saying is chris wallace said one
thing that that makes sense
um the reason i do those disclaimers is
for my own sake it's actually selfish
i'm being selfish when i do it and i'll
explain why if i talk about
um different plans for health care and i
say there's medicare for all and there's
this other type of plan here are
different types of plans
if i don't clarify i'm not saying i want
for-profit health
right if i don't clarify that i will get
no exaggeration
100 emails clogging my inbox from people
saying david how dare you
how dare you support for-profit health
insurance
so the reason i give the disclaimer and
i say hey i'm telling you something that
exists
i'm not advocating for it i
will get a hundred emails when i do the
disclaimer i only get
40. all right it's merely agreed that i
don't know it's not even greed
it's a concern for my own inbox that's
why i do the disclaimers
i agree that it's sad i do um
but it is what it is and if you saw what
was going on with my inbox every day
you would also understand it we have a
great bonus show for you today
get instant access by becoming a member
at joinpacman.com i'll speak to you on
the bonus show
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
magic spoon is the cereal that tastes
exactly like the delicious cereals from
your childhood except it has no sugar
tons of protein and only three net carbs
so it's perfect for
a keto diet to get free shipping go to
magicspoon.com
pacman and use the code pacman blinkist
is the app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an entire nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman